it's that time of the month again so
only have revealed the PlayStation Plus
lineup for February 2017 Knicks games
are here for you to try this month which
will be available to download from
Tuesday February the 7th both Vita games
are accessible on ps3 and ps4 so please
stick around even if you don't have a
Vita we have a really strange bunch of
games for you this month so as always
let's check out the ps4 releases first
Little Big Planet 3 heads up the month
on ps4 and follows in the footsteps of
the super enjoyable original sadly the
development team behind the original
Media Molecule
have been replaced by sumo digital who
seem to have missed the nuances that
make the C restore renowned but what
they lack in originality they make up
for in sheer scope and story too
the narrative is suitable for the whole
family and there are many references to
film and video games at its heart this
is a platformer but the controls will
annoy you regularly but if you need a
heat of Sackboy for nostalgic purposes
or you never really clear the
LittleBigPlanet game keep this one ago
current Metacritic score 79 percent not
the hero is the ps4 indie title which
embraces retro graphics and colors you
play as a rabbit bunny Lord who has
travel back in time from the Year 2048
to be elected man save the world from an
alien invasion yep this is one messed up
game which does not take itself
seriously in the slightest it's a 2d
cover shooter with 84 challenges to
uncover Metacritic has this one at 74%
Before we jump over to the ps3 please do
as a favor and subscribe to help us
reach more people we are a small Channel
but we have big ambitions so please help
us out right let's get back to more Egan
the first time on ps3 is also available
on ps4 and goes by the name star wall ok
so I know what you're going to say this
looks terrible well it may not look
great to many people it keeps
surprisingly good when you get your
friends around to flip you play is one
of four now walls also known as the
unicorn of the sea and that bit is quite
important because the weapon of choice
is the horn on your head PS ER friends
through there now all heart and be
victorious go on give it a go next up is
Anna the extended edition on ps3 this is
a psychological horror game released in
2012 and it's also set in a sawmill
think of this game like a four month
resident evil' seven and you have with
that for a twenty-twelve gear it has
aged remarkably well and the story is
linked to um Negus or new information
pops up regularly and makes you rethink
your actions steam users give this one
six out of ten the hidden gem that is
the Vita has two further games for us
this month and both of these titles are
playable on ps4 and ps3 first up is
ninja sin key DX a platformer in the
style of Mega Man it's a typical boy
meets girl girl gets killed by a demon
voice valves revenge what you see is
definitely what you get with this one so
what do you think please let me know in
the comments below and finally yet
another cross by title in the [ __ ] of
torque else or torkoal I'm not sure
about that one
what the heck can I say about this one
you know what I'm not going to say
anything and just let you take in those
fine fine graphics so we started off
strong but things went a little bit
downhill on this month's PS Plus what
will you be picking up please complete
the story in the comments below they
won't read them by the way I'm going to
pick up Little Big Planet 3 and I'm
actually looking forward to playing Star
wall I'm Adam from PlayStation grenade
I'll see you next time